Patrick what would you tell to a young
filmmaker starting out or even someone
beyond that wants to start documentary
filmmaking on the side as a hobby and
see how they like it yeah go in there
what would I tell an aspiring
documentary filmmaker there's some of
the steps it's like from watching great
films yeah definite watching great films
for sure um but shooting as much as
possible I think is the key to kind of
developing a style developing an
aesthetic and a voice I think is really
about finding your what your voices
there's just some there's so many films
in the marketplace that are kind of all
the same you know I mean like same vibe
same tone saying boys and write an
original and it's the ones who develop
these original voices and have something
unique to say in a unique way to say it
that kind of rise to the top you know
you're just course az's and whatnot you
know like they have original voices
original ways of telling a story and the
only way to find that is through you
know watching antenna films and being
very conscious of what sort of moves you
and what speaks to and then going out
with your camera cameras are so cheap
now there's no there's no excuse for not
being able to go out and do this but
yeah going with the camera just shooting
as much as possible and bring it back I
movie Final Cut Pro whatever and cutting
pieces together and getting a feel for
what it's what it feels like to tell
stories and from your own perspective
that's that's the key I think finding
your voice
you